they look like something out of an
Indiana Jones movie bridges made out of
living trees
this is non-greed a remote village in
northeastern India where locals have
been growing bridges for hundreds of
years
coming up spot all this pot I bet I'd
get him
that's Whiston moi the head of the
village he's lived here his whole life
since 1952
whatever just a community to make sure
lucky good product to me he said he got
to moving to be intriguing huh he didn't
kill a man Rocky what Chicago bar
couldn't come okay I tell you now I'm
gonna come for soup and that you like
had one realtor make the realtor to get
the roots to grow into a bridge across
water they use wire and old tree trunks
to guide their path they open no big
mile of anything like that but I'm like
give me anything
we don't read down and up Rufus
auctioning you're gonna get in team but
they talk about Erica alone yet maybe
with us nah my god
you can give me again gasps no bubble
wrap and POW possible Brunei Darussalam
below one ban Sigma Chi 1 / K giggles ok
have a paper box and in the super you
will see
you